lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
resolver un problema que es un poco
complicado como para verlo en una clase
de física de primer año y de hecho es
muy poco probable que se encuentren este
tipo de problemas en estos cursos
básicos de física sin embargo es un
problema bastante interesante ya que lo
que vamos a hacer es lanzar un proyectil
en un plano inclinado podemos imaginar
que esto y esto de acá es una ladera y
digamos que conocemos la inclinación de
esta ladera que es de 30 grados por
encima de la horizontal
esta es la horizontal y nosotros vamos a
lanzar un proyectil con una velocidad de
10 metros por segundo
y el ángulo que forma este proyectil con
la ladera este ángulo de acá es de 15
grados lo remarcó mejor para que se note
y 10 metros por segundo la velocidad el
ángulo con la ladera es de 15 grados y
la razón por la que este tipo de
problemas es más difícil que aquellos
que hemos visto con respecto al
lanzamiento de proyectiles es que si lo
pensamos pues bueno el proyectil va a
ser lanzado así
y va a caer en algún momento acá pero no
podemos usar el método simple para
calcular cuánto tiempo está en el aire
usando el componente vertical y
horizontal porque no podemos conocer su
componente vertical ya que ya que no
sabemos qué tan lejos va a llegar en la
horizontal si nosotros superamos qué tan
lejos llega aquí en el componente
horizontal entonces podríamos calcular
la componente vertical de la velocidad
así que aquí tenemos que encontrar los
componentes horizontales y verticales al
mismo tiempo ya que mientras más lejos
llegue en el componente horizontal más
alto será su componente vertical pero
veremos paso a paso cómo resolver esto y
lo que siempre hay que hacer en este
tipo de problemas es descomponer nuestro
vector velocidad en sus elementos
horizontal y vertical
el componente vertical de la velocidad
va a ser igual a la magnitud de la
velocidad qué es
10 metros por segundo y aquí hay que
tener mucho cuidado ya que no va a ser
el seno de 15 grados sino el seno de
este ángulo con respecto a la horizontal
vamos a tener que tomar en cuenta todo
este ángulo de acá la suma de estos dos
ángulos de 45 grados por lo tanto esto
va a estar multiplicado por el seno
de 45 grados y ya hemos visto que dónde
sale esto en vídeos anteriores pero por
cuestiones de tiempo vamos a omitirlos
si ustedes tienen dudas les recomiendo
que revisen los vídeos anteriores para
ver de dónde sale esto básicamente esto
viene de soca toa de nuestras funciones
trigonométricas ya que nuestro
componente vertical luce algo así y con
respecto a este ángulo este lado es el
lado opuesto y de esas funciones
trigonométricas su seno es igual al
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa por
eso es que aquí usamos seno del ángulo
para representar la magnitud de este
lado de este componente vertical vamos a
quitar algunas de las cosas que puse
para dejar el dibujo un poco más claro y
el componente horizontal de la velocidad
va a seguir la misma lógica va a ser
igual a la magnitud de la velocidad
el coseno del ángulo que forma el vector
velocidad con la horizontal que es de 45
grados
ahora pensemos cuál va a ser nuestro
desplazamiento vertical bueno voy a usar
la fórmula que hemos encontrado en
vídeos anteriores directamente nuestro
desplazamiento vertical va a ser igual
nuestra velocidad vertical inicial va a
ser igual a 10 por seno de 45 grados es
más podemos de una vez encontrar el
valor de esto el seno de 45 grados es
igual a raíz cuadrada de 2 entre 2 y el
coseno de 45 grados también es igual a
raíz cuadrada de 2 entre 2
así que el valor de aquí
5 x raíz cuadrada de 2 y el mismo valor
tenemos acá 10 x raíz cuadrada de 2
entre 12 es igual a 5 x raíz cuadrada de
2 y no olvidemos también las unidades
estos son metros por segundo ya que
estoy hablando de velocidad y aquí
también son metros por segundo y con
esto ya simplificamos un poquito
nuestros cálculos pero regresamos a lo
que estábamos trabajando estábamos
diciendo que nuestro desplazamiento
vertical va a ser igual a nuestra
velocidad vertical inicial que
encontramos es 5 por raíz cuadrada de 2
x nuestro cambio en el tiempo por
nuestro cambio en el tiempo más la
aceleración pero sabemos que la
aceleración es menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado quitamos este más y
dejamos menos va a ser menos 9.8 no
escribo las unidades para ahorrar
espacio x nuestro cambio en el tiempo al
cuadrado
y todo esto dividido entre 2
esta fórmula la deducimos con detalle en
vídeos anteriores especialmente en el
vídeo anterior en donde vimos el
movimiento de proyectiles en dos
dimensiones así que todo esto nos da el
desplazamiento en nuestra dirección y
vamos a simplificar esto mi
desplazamiento vertical es igual a 5 por
raíz de 2 por el cambio en el tiempo
menos 9.8 entre 2 es 4.9 delta de al
cuadrado así que ya tenemos esta
restricción que nos da nuestro
desplazamiento vertical como una función
del tiempo ahora encontremos nuestro
desplazamiento horizontal como función
del tiempo nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal va a ser igual a nuestra
velocidad horizontal inicial que es esto
5 x raíz cuadrada de 2 x el cambio en el
tiempo ahora que vamos a hacer pues
tenemos que encontrar una especie de
relación entre nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal y nuestro desplazamiento
vertical
relación va a estar dada mediante esta
inclinación este plano inclinado así que
dondequiera que vemos contra esta ladera
digamos que vamos a caer aquí
eventualmente cuando hacer el
desplazamiento vertical y horizontal en
este punto si el proyectil cae aquí aquí
vamos a tener su desplazamiento vertical
y para este punto su desplazamiento
horizontal será
este
desplazamiento en x cuando haces la
relación entre desplazamiento vertical y
el desplazamiento horizontal bueno
nosotros sabemos que este ángulo de aquí
es de 30 grados y recordando nuestra
trigonometría básica ya que este es un
triángulo rectángulo sabemos que tenemos
este lado opuesto y tenemos este lado
adyacente la función trigonométricas que
relaciona o que usa el lado opuesto y el
lado adyacente es tangente tangente es
igual al lado opuesto entre el adyacente
así que nuestra tangente de 30 grados va
a ser igual a la magnitud del componente
vertical
entre la magnitud del componente
horizontal
y sabemos que la tangente de 30 grados
es igual al seno de 30 grados entre el
coseno de 30 grados y sabemos que el
seno de 30 grados es igual a un medio y
el coseno de 30 grados es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 esto es igual
a un medio por 2 entre la raíz cuadrada
de 3 estos dos se van y me queda que
esto es igual a 1 entre raíz cuadrada de
3 así que la magnitud de nuestro
componente vertical entre la magnitud de
nuestro componente horizontal va a ser
igual a 1 entre raíz cuadrada de 3 igual
a 1 entre raíz cuadrada de 3
esto de aquí
y esto nos sirve para darnos una
relación entre nuestro componente
vertical y nuestro componente horizontal
y podemos usar esta recepción para
despejar una de estas dos vamos a hacer
vamos a escribir explícitamente esto
vamos a hacer una multiplicación cruzada
que es lo mismo que multiplicar todo por
raíz cuadrada de tres y la magnitud de
nuestro componente horizontal nos va a
quedar
y la raíz cuadrada de 3 x por nuestro
componente vertical
va a ser igual a la magnitud de nuestro
componente horizontal
ahora tenemos una relación entre la
longitud de ambos vectores y podemos
usar esta relación para sustituir las
restricciones que encontramos con
anterioridad ahora usemos esta
restricción
el desplazamiento horizontal es igual a
5 por raíz cuadrada de 2 por el cambio
en el tiempo otra forma de ver esto es
si dividimos ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre 5 por raíz cuadrada de 2
nos queda que el cambio en el tiempo es
igual a nuestro componente horizontal
entre 5 x raíz cuadrada de 2 pero
nosotros también sabemos que este
desplazamiento horizontal es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 3 por la magnitud del
desplazamiento vertical y aquí
explícitamente escribir la magnitud del
componente vertical sin embargo aquí lo
puedo dejar así ya que la misma cantidad
va a expresar su dirección y de hecho
por la forma en que los dibuje a ambos
componentes van a ser positivos ya que
nuestro desplazamiento hacia arriba es
positivo de acuerdo a la convención que
ya tenemos y el desplazamiento hacia la
derecha también es positivo así que
puedo expresar
estoy acá como raíz cuadrada de 3 raíz
cuadrada de 3 x nuestro desplazamiento
vertical todo esto entre 5 x raíz
cuadrada de 2 hice esto porque teniendo
el cambio en el tiempo expresado así
como una función del desplazamiento
vertical contiene esta información la
proporción entre nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal y nuestro desplazamiento
vertical y también contiene la
información de como nuestro
desplazamiento horizontal cambia con
respecto al tiempo así que nuestro
tiempo
va a ser igual a esto el tiempo como
función de nuestro desplazamiento
vertical en lugar de como función del
desplazamiento horizontal y ahora lo que
podemos hacer es usar esta restricción
con nuestra fórmula del desplazamiento
original ahora sustituyamos esto en
estas delta test de aquí lo voy a
escribir grande aquí abajo nuestro
desplazamiento vertical es igual a 5 por
raíz cuadrada de 2
por nuestro cambio en el tiempo pero ya
queremos que nuestro cambio en el tiempo
es todo esto así que va a estar x raíz
cuadrada de 3 por el cambio por el
desplazamiento vertical entre 5 x raíz
cuadrada de 2 y esto de hecho esta es la
fórmula que vamos a usar que ya está
simplificada esto menos 4.9 por delta t
nuevamente del tate es raíz cuadrada de
3 por el desplazamiento vertical
entre 5 x raíz cuadrada de 2
todo esto elevado al cuadrado y ahora
nos queda una ecuación cuadrática con
solo una variable así que la podemos
encontrar vamos a simplificar la así que
nuestro componente vertical
es igual a 5 por raíz de 2 entre 5 por
raíz de 2 se cancelan y nos quedan raíz
cuadrada de 3 por la magnitud de nuestro
desplazamiento vertical aunque no
escribo explícitamente la magnitud acá
menos 4.9 por esto de aquí al cuadrado
así que nos queda raíz cuadrada de 3 al
cuadrado es 3 por desplazamiento
vertical al cuadrado entre 5 al cuadrado
5 por 5 25 por raíz de 2 al cuadrado 225
por 2 es igual a 50 si restamos este
desplazamiento vertical en ambos lados
de esta ecuación voy a hacer un poquito
más de espacio para que se note mejor
nos va a quedar 0 igual la raíz cuadrada
de 3 por el desplazamiento vertical
menos 1 por el desplazamiento vertical
esto viene de que este desplazamiento
vertical está s
estando aquí y aquí también tengo esta
es ella así que factor hizo la sg y me
queda raíz cuadrada de tres menos uno
todo por mi componente vertical menos
4.9 por tres entre 50 por nuestro
componente vertical al cuadrado y aquí
podemos factorizar uno de nuestros
componentes verticales así que esto va a
ser igual
la raíz cuadrada de tres menos uno
- 4.9 por tres entre 50s y
por la componente vertical que factor
izamos s
así que para que esta igualdad sea
verdadera ya sea que esté componente
vertical sea igual a 0 ya que está
multiplicando esto y cualquier número x
0 da cero o que todo esto de aquí todo
eso de aquí sea igual a cero y de hecho
el que nos interesa es este ya que
cuando tenemos el desplazamiento
vertical igual a cero es justo cuando
apenas estamos lanzando el proyectil no
tiene un desplazamiento vertical está en
el punto de origen sin embargo esto nos
va a dar el desplazamiento vertical una
vez que ya fue lanzado ese proyectil así
que pues bueno vamos a calcular todo
esto de una vez para evitar estar
escribiendo tanto vamos a usar nuestra
calculadora así que la raíz cuadrada de
tres menos uno es igual a punto 2 732
hago espacio y lo escribo acá esta parte
cita de aquí la redondeo apuntó 732
y 4.9 por 3 entre 50 va a ser igual
punto 294 esto de aquí
menos
0 puntos 294 por nuestro componente
vertical todo esto debe ser igual a 0 ya
sea que esto es igual a 0 o éste es
igual a 0 hacemos aún más espacio aunque
ya estamos casi por terminar
sumamos punto 294 s en ambos lados y nos
queda 0 puntos 732 igual a 0 punto 294 s
ii y ahora dividimos ambos lados entre
punto 294
nos queda que el desplazamiento vertical
es igual a cero punto 732 en 30 punto
294 y así tenemos nuestro componente
vertical y merece un redoble de tambores
llegar a este punto sacamos la
calculadora y ponemos puntos 732 entre
punto 294 y nos da un desplazamiento
vertical de 2.489 y lo podemos redondear
a 2.49 metros así que esto es igual a
2.49 metros genial ahora podemos poner
esto aquí esto es igual a 2.49 metros y
ahora ya podemos encontrar nuestro
desplazamiento horizontal fácilmente ya
que sabemos que nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal es nuestro desplazamiento
vertical multiplicado por la raíz
cuadrada de 3 vamos a calcularlo
aquí tenemos nuestro desplazamiento
vertical y esto lo multiplicamos por
raíz cuadrada de 3
y nos da 4.31 metros nuestro
desplazamiento horizontal es igual a
4.31 metros y ahora conocemos el
desplazamiento horizontal y también el
desplazamiento vertical y ahora les
dejaré a ustedes como tarea que calculen
exactamente qué tan lejos llegó este
proyectil en este plano inclinado y para
esto para calcular esta distancia
ustedes pueden usar estos dos valores
estos dos desplazamientos también pueden
usar el teorema de pitágoras para
encontrar esto finalmente ya conocen los
lados del triángulo y les faltaría
conocer la hipotenusa